♪
BRIAN: CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF NOW
CALLING FOR INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION TO INVESTIGATE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE TO
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
THE CONGRESSMAN TWEETING AFTER
PEARL HARBOR AND 9/11 WE LOOKED
AT WHAT WENT WRONG TO LEARN FROM
OUR MISTAKES.
ONCE WE RECOVERED WE NEED A
NONPARTISAN COMMISSION TO REVIEW
OUR RESPONSE AND HOW WE CAN BE
BETTER PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
PANDEMIC.
I’M WORKING ON A BILL TO DO
THAT.
JOINING US NOW TO REACT RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CONGRESSMAN DOUG
COLLINS OFTEN BY ADAM SCHIFF’S
SIDE BUT MAYBE NOT ON THE SAME
SIDE.
CONGRESSMAN, IS THIS THE TIME TO
BRING UP A COMMISSION?
>> NO.
IT’S NOT.
AND I THINK, LOOK, THERE IS
GOING TO BE ENOUGH WITH THE
PACKAGES WE PASSED OF AID GOING
TO PEOPLE IN THE STARTING IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
WE HAVE OVERSIGHT IN THAT WE
HAVE INSPECTOR GENERAL, THERE IS
STUFF PUT IN THERE TO MAKE SURE.
AND LOOK AT A CERTAIN POINT IN
TIME THERE WILL BE A BOOK BACK
AT THISTHERE WILL BE A LOOK BACK
BACK I’M NOT SURE HE WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT.
CHINA’S ROLE IN THIS AS
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
HE WAS SO WRAPPED UP IN
IMPEACHMENT WHEN THAT YOU WILL
HIT I’M NOT SURE THERE WAS A
SLOW RESPONSE ON BOTH SIDES NO
ONE WAS LOOKING AT THIS BECAUSE
HE WAS SO FOCUSED ON THE
PRESIDENT AND WHAT HE WAS TRYING
TO DO IN THE ELECTION WE WERE
MISSING CHINA AND OTHERS.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE.
I’M NOT SURE HE WOULD LIKE THE
OUTCOME OF THIS REPORT ANY MORE
THAN ANY OF THE OTHER REPORTS HE
HAD THIS YEAR.
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
AND THE RISE OF AL-QAEDA WAS
MUTED BY THE FACT THAT PRESIDENT
CLINTON WAS SO CAUGHT UP IN HIS
OWN IMPEACHMENT.
I HOPE WE START LEARNING FROM.
THIS MEANWHILE, ON THE TERMS OF
IMPEACHMENT, ADAM SCHIFF WAS
ASKED, DID YOUR IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY HURT THE PRESIDENT BEING
ABLE TO LOOK AFTER THE POTENTIAL
PANDEMIC?
HERE IS HIS RESPONSE.
>> MITCH McCONNELL SAID THAT
HE BELIEVES THAT THE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL IN THE SENATE SLOWED DOWN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’S
RESPONSE.
>> THE PERSON SAID SOMETHING
SIMILAR WHICH, YOU KNOW, WAS AN
INTERESTING ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SCREWED
UP THIS RESPONSE.
AND I THINK THE FACTS ARE QUITE
CLEAR THAT THE PRESIDENT WEEKS’
LONG MAYBE MONTHS LONG DELAY IN
TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY HAS HAD
CATASTROPHIC CONSEQUENCES.
BRIAN: WHAT’S YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT.
>> BRIAN, HE CAN’T HELP HIMSELF.
THIS IS MAN WHO FOR A YEAR HAS
DONE NOTHING OVER A YEAR HAS
ATTACKED THIS PRESIDENT.
TRIED TO GO THROUGH THE MUELLER
REPORT, THE IMPEACHMENT HE SAID
THE PRESIDENT DID IN PLAIN SIGHT
DID WRONGDOING.
HE CAN’T HELP HIMSELF.
HE IS EVEN IN ISOLATION IT
SOUNDS LIKE ALL HE WANTS TO DO
IS FOCUS ON THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE A GOOD
JOB AS IS HE FOCUSED ON THIS.
WE HAVE ALL LEARNED FROM THIS
CRISIS AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN LISTENING TO THE ADVISORS
AND MOVING FORWARD.
BUT THERE CAN BE NO MISTAKE THAT
IN THE MONTH OF JANUARY AND
DECEMBER WHEN ADAM SCHIFF WAS
LEADING THIS COUNTRY DOWN A SHAM
IMPEACHMENT THAT THERE WAS
DISTRACTION ON CAPITOL HILL.
YOU SAW IT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE THAT THEY WERE SO FOCUSED
ON THIS.
YOU KNOW, FOR HIM TO COME BACK
AT THIS POINT AND TRY TO REGAIN
THE SPOTLIGHT FROM HIS FAILED
ATTEMPTS AT IMPEACHMENT IS SAD
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING ON WHAT’S
HAPPENING NOW.
GETTING THE DRUGS THAT YOU JUST
TALKED ABOUT WITH DR. OZ.
GETTING THESE FOLKS THE MONEY
THAT THEY NEED SO THAT OUR
ECONOMY CAN RECOVER AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS AND BEING TAKING
CARE OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOSING FAMILY MEMBERS AND LOSING
LIVES AND LOSING BUSINESSES
RIGHT NOW.
AGAIN, THIS IS SO PREMATURE BUT
FRANKLY IT’S NOT NOTHING NEW FOR
ADAM SCHIFF.
BRIAN: THE THING IS, CONGRESSMAN
COLLINS, ANTHONY FAUCI WAS ON
THE RADIO SHOW JANUARY 26TH
SAYING I DON’T THINK THAT VIRUS
FROM WHAT THEY KNOW IS GOING TO
BE A BIG PROBLEM HERE.
SO THE BEST IN THE BUSINESS WHO
BASICALLY PUSHED AMERICA TOWARDS
A CURE FOR AIDES WAS FOR AIDS WA
SURPRISE.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT THE PRESIDENT
AND CIVILIANS TO PICK UP THE
MAGNITUDE OF WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING.
ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE TO BLAME.
IT’S THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WHO
STILL IS NOT TELLING US THE
TRUTH.
THIS IS ONE TIME IN WHICH WE
DON’T HAVE TO BE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS WE CAN BE AMERICANS
AND, AGAIN, WE ARE BACK TO THE
SAME OLD DIVIDE.
I WISH PEOPLE WOULD START
GROWING UP.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY
DIPLOMATIC YESTERDAY WHEN HE
SAID THOSE NUMBERS WERE LIKE --
I THINK WE CAN AGREE REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATS THE NUMBERS WERE
WRONG.
DR. FAUCI’S STATEMENT AND OTHERS
IT JUST SHOWS THEY WERE NOT
BEING FORTH RIGHT IN THE
OUTCOMING OF THIS -- OF THEIR
REPORTS AND WHAT THEY WERE
SEEING AND NOW IT’S TIME FOR US
TO COME TOGETHER, ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT AND MOVE TOWARD TAKING CARE
OF THE PEOPLE WHO NEED THE HELP
OF EACH OTHER AS AMERICANS.
WE ALWAYS PULL TOGETHER.
WE ARE IN THIS TOGETHER AND WE
HAVE GOT TO CONTINUE THIS FIGHT
RIGHT NOW.
BRIAN: GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR
SENATE RUN.
I KNOW IT’S VETTING VERY HARD
REMOTE BUT EVERYONE IS DEALING